you know when you're 12 years old and 13
years old and every teacher you have
tells you that you're going to be a
loser and a garbage man but that was the
hot thing in the 80s you're gonna be a
garbage man I was like oh [__] you know
I was like I was actually kind of Pumped
I'm like oh [__] I can get stuff for
free instead of garage sales and flip it
you know but
that was hard I think that's why I'm
unstoppable now because every grown-up I
knew told me I was going to be a loser
while my mother told me I wasn't and the
world told me I wasn't I was selling
lemonade shoveling snow selling baseball
cards slipping stuff at garage sales and
I was great at it the market told me I
was great my mom told me I was great
because I was a nice person and here I
am 46 years later a nice gangster
businessman and built a personal brand
because I can deal with people [__]
on me